on this episode Jason Calacanis stops by
[Music]
[Music]
this is
ask Gary B hey everybody it's gary
vay-ner-chuk and this episode - 33 of
the ask gary vee show two of my favorite
people are here Jason Calacanis and
India India why are you even here this
is amazing I'm excited Elliot are you
sad show sad Elliot sad Elliot I love it
India very good to see you but Jason
more importantly for the four people
that don't know who you are why don't
you give them a 30 to 75 second bio I'm
a angel investor I create me tell you
start with know I start getting I say I
say things all the time
exactly no it started soaking our
reporter here in New York so I started a
bunch of Internet companies mainly in
publishing and I am an angel investor
and commentator I'm kind of like the
West Coast version of Gary Vee I like
the Knicks you're their Jets yep your
ambition is to buy the Knicks
yeah like seeing the garden it's getting
harder and harder the value of these
come I know the TV deals we're not being
more successful than the value of these
guys ago they're getting worse well it's
great but not fast enough it's to the
gap well the good news for me with the
NFL is that ultimately has a decline
with cushions and this and that and so
we'll see but anyway so what's been
going on a lot of a lot of people you
know 20 I have a lot of young young
young entrepreneurs and a little bit
more like not old just tech where you
have enormous names so I think for a lot
of people look I think we're from my
standpoint from afar and we've
interacted a bunch is he just execute
some hustles I like that very early web
1.0 kind of entrepreneur I started when
the web was no images no video the 90s
here in New York it was pretty exciting
we all knew what we get big but it took
longer than we all thought right yeah
kids right like by the year 2000 it felt
like I remember Wine Library was gonna
sell all of its wine on Wine Library by
the year 2002 you know this device that
chart was raw an expected game-changer
game-changer because we never expected
you would have a supercomputer your
pocket with a broadband connect didn't
we find the video on Wine Library TV
where I'm like you can use Twitter on
your phone now we need to pull that up
yeah
do you have it
I wish is that should I tweet about uber
when one was it when did I say when was
the video from 2007 to 32 which is whoa
and this is what 233 oh we almost that
would have been great that would have an
amazing recall but things change fast
you know like super bang at this and
Jase you know one of the few guys in
that angel ecosystem that I grew up with
that was smart enough to invest in the
angel round of uber yeah
one of the things you learn about being
an angel investor is you don't have to
know if the companies didn't succeed you
just need to know if the person's good
and tragic about it yet and you just
knew a Travis that he's into fatigue of
all he's a hustler he's hard-working I
mean and I passed on Twitter and Singha
because I couldn't figure out the
businesses and that's when I was like
you know what I'm betting on horses
exactly any Williams who mark pink
Johnny whatever they do that's right yep
you got it just bet the person and their
ability to figure it out talking about
great people let's go to India India
let's get into the first question
oh here we go oh video opinion from rez
rusty hey what's up Gary Vee my name is
Brian aka my new bun I monkey app
musically and I have a following of over
600,000 people not only that but I'm one
of four musically reps that live in New
York City so my question is I don't know
what to do next I feel like I'm stuck in
a plateau I don't know what to do next
I I love making these videos now
musically but I'm also pushing everybody
to YouTube - I asked this question
because I have friends who have less
followers of me who have managers and
people who I know that have millions of
fans who don't who don't even have
managers or they don't even know what to
do so what should I do next with this
following do I go out there and look for
companies or brand deals or should I
link up with a manager or what should I
do I put my business email out there and
I'm not always getting emails every day
or something I I am patient I do wait
but lately I'm just trying to figure out
a way to get a source of income from
this because again I do love doing this
I love doing this but at the end of the
day I still have my mom harassing me
saying
a are you gonna get a job or just in
that and yeah so Gary what should I do
so Jason it's fun to have you here with
this question good job by you guys
curating because again we lived through
early bloggers getting famous then
Twitter was really the first preview to
this where both of us were lucky enough
to be one of those hundred 150 people
that every letter is following what kind
of advice do you give to you know
there's I'm paying a lot of tension to
the musically stars is the youngest
generation of stars we ever say you're
making a joke of vaynermedia being young
and we're talking about 9 10 11 12 year
old stars could since it's Nickelodeon
up in musically right now what's your
what's your advice for this well I mean
what is the goal here like this a person
want to be active a actually have any
raw talent are they actually a musician
are they actually a singer or are they
just kind of becoming popular for doing
why do you think that's becoming do you
think that's possibly becoming just
talent itself like you know if
everything you said that and I'm
debating it myself right do you actually
have a skill so what I think is adding
skills to your repertoire like that can
only help you so if you learn an
instrument if you actually learn to sing
then you can kind of take it to the next
level so when you saw Justin Bieber on
YouTube it was like yeah he's a YouTube
star but he actually had core talent no
he was a real talent he was a real
talent then you look at somebody like
King batch yes on fine that's just the
number one guy for a while it probably
still is like he actually is funny
because real comedians a real comedian
actor at guess erase comedic actors yeah
so I think adding skills when you're a
young person is one thing that this
generation and there's no back words
like they go get the fame and it's great
you can hit that lightning a bottle but
get that skill you can never it can
never be taken away from you yeah I
think ills
I think networking I think just even
asking this question like for example
I'm interested I'm spending more time in
musically so let's get this kid into my
office I want to meet him for 20 minutes
and you just need to do that over and
over right how many people have been
able to get to you and met for 15 or 30
minutes just by pounding you on social
and email for the last decade give me a
rough estimate of number cuz I know
4,000 10,000 you've had but you write
and some people they email you one time
in you gave me 15 minutes
and some people million thirty seven
thousand times in
never talk to them exactly that's that's
the punch I get the quality like I look
for people with the job you know this
it's a subjective moment in time
sure like at that moment it felt like
right yeah I'm it's a crapshoot
yeah but you know what it's a numbers
game if you one of the things is I had
an invest I have a portfolio company
that raised money from seven people and
they're like we can't raise any more
money it's not working I'm like well
how'd you get the first seven like well
we met with like a ton of people's
economy they said 15 I was like so you
can raise money from 50% of if you be
with and now you know with another five
you didn't get an investor so you're
quitting like so soft you got to do at
least 50 meetings and what you do is you
take notes after every meeting and you
ask people candidly why did you pass on
investing it the way you could help me I
understand your passing is just can you
just tell me the truth and just end it
with me and tell me why I suck or tell
me what I need to work on you know what
people will do it if you give them
permission to speak freely love it India
let's move it forward by the way I'm
serious I want to meet the kid make it
happen
fail man oh hey Gary it's a Canadian
homies wish I had a question for you
very short and sweet what's your career
advice to d-roc and how he can progress
his career because he's a madly talented
person and I know for sure you want the
best at it and a great question for me I
think d-roc needs to hold on to me for
dear life because I think he's grossly
overrated because of the fame and
stardom of my amazing ability and so if
I was Dirac I'd be holding on for dear
life is this one of your whack Packers
no that's d-roc so do you rock so he he
is obviously filming dailyvee and you've
got clearly he's got video skills and
he's built in no I mean now when we I
take a song even here how long you been
heard you were on to it in that beer let
me tell you something about loyalty it's
year three and four when the magic
happens everybody wants to bounce after
a year or two go to the next day because
somebody's would go oh do you rocks
associated with him let me give him a
10% bump in salary I jump over there but
I'm telling you for a hundred when
you're making to power United but I
always find that people who stick around
for a year three four or five in a
start-up they kind of ascend to this
level and they learn some stuff and you
want to learn when you're young and the
problem is a lot of people don't put
that
they quit too early I think the big
thing is um you've got I agree in some
ways and I'll go slightly different you
just have to reverse engineer what you
got to deploy as much self-awareness as
you have this moment and the reverse
engineer what you want if the rock wants
for example if the rock wants to make a
movie for real write a feature film he's
never been in a better position with me
because if as long as he keeps believing
in me and as long as I keep proving that
I continue to grow I'm closer to being
able to fund a future I can fund a
future film now like it's raising mom
like I don't want to know why ID rock
but you know I I think I think's but you
just have to know what you want I think
I think that my career advice man oh -
you too dear och India other Tyler Andy
the Jason to myself is know what you
want and put yourself in the best
position to succeed to get there but be
careful because the thing right in front
of you is normally not the thing that's
actually gonna get you to the best
position to actually do what you want
hmm
anyhow but you're in the game that's
important yes crazy video yeah a minute
44 Gary Gary Gary Vaynerchuk hey you
remember when episode 3 you said it
should be a life dream to get your
question on my show Gary it's my life
treatment please India come on girl get
me on the show just getting India you're
awesome I love you hey I'm really glad
you didn't get fired we were worried we
were worried vaynernation was worried
Hey
tear up get our cameras get together and
focus ha ha ha I'm Zeke fit freak coming
from you from Valparaiso Indiana
cornfields and everything oh god help me
I need a mount somebody give me a
mountain I'm a personal trainer and a
lifestyle manager oh that's a new one
lifestyle manju what does that even mean
I'll tell you but I let you let's just
get to the question ok no we're really I
love what you're saying about
self-awareness it's one of the number
one things I talk to my clients about
one of the number of things that has
changed my life for the better in so
many different ways but being truly
self-aware I know that one of my best
talents obviously is the energy that I
bring to the table and I'm telling you
I'll bring this energy to the table
wherever I'm at ok call me out there
right now I'm gonna drive out that you
think I won't
I will bring this energy Gary and I know
this would be really great for brands
but I'm trying to brand my own thing on
the side right so the question is how do
you harness and an emotion that comes
through the energy that I develop and
give and share with other people how can
i monetize that online um I've been
working on it and I could really use
your help
thank you so much Gary I Love You Man
hey vrock link in description Oh get
right there right there
lift life God and go New York Jax Wow
Jason what are you doing with that
wow thanks jim carrey he's really
clearly that's really got some
interesting charisma what do you think
how does he monetize all that energy
well here's the thing we both know
online is a great way to get attention
it's it's a little bit challenging
sometimes to monetize I was the cp/m so
very low it's hard to get to the brands
that's why big agencies like yours exist
and other ones around town they have the
bread relationships there'll be some
opportunity to join these networks of
stars you know about those
yep that's a fine way to do it but I
think building a brand online and then
increasing your prices offline so if
he's a trainer and he's got five clients
and they're all paying 50 bucks an hour
what I was find is people are afraid to
raise their prices and lose clients
right so if he keeps growing and he's
that good you know he should be able to
raise his doubles price then double your
price then double your price and you
know maybe have five people who are
paying $400 a session or that kind of
thing so be good at whatever your skill
is and then keep raising your price
products services content there's only
four to five things that one can gear to
monetize yeah you've got great energy
you get intention you get you get you
build a base and then you can do a lot
of different things you could sell them
stuff right make a product into it
you can sell a t-shirt like you can sell
them a physical thing you can create a
service if you train people and it's 50
bucks an hour then it's 100 then it's
200 you can be in a place where you as a
personality gets modified you signed a
book deal you sell a lot of them you
speak for a hundred bucks than a
thousand bucks and five thousand bucks
you create a scalable content play you
put out something that is you know you
put your classes on udemy and all these
kind of things you collect creative
collective and things like that so you
and I can give you like a lot of things
but like
truth is there's only like five or six
things that are out there rookie mistake
when I talk to somebody say what's your
business model and they say well it's
going to be advertising and
subscriptions and then we're going to
sell things and then we're going to sell
the data and they list 18 things and
it's like whoa the great companies uber
take a percentage tumblr advertising
Google ad network right it's very rare
that you see even a big company Apple
selling Hardware goes into a second or
third business on you have to pick one
and go to it and just master it because
you know how hard it is to get
advertising and content to work you have
to be the number one person in your
category and you have to a very tight
relationship so you have to deliver for
those advertisers on a product basis
people who are making great products and
selling them at a high profit like Apple
man it's hard to compete against people
like that you have to be exceptional in
this the other thing for a lot of you
that are watching that I think will be
valuable is try to do everything give a
free speech create a content ebook go
try to get a publishing deal like try
different things see which one's work
yeah see more like what you enjoy yeah I
think some critical to because if you
don't enjoy being in a service business
and having customers like you can't do
it cuz you're I got all my tech friends
as you like you know like like from what
I came from they're like you like this
like you like having them like I'm like
I like it cuz I know what it's building
for me long term but it's you know like
nobody in tech wants the unscalable
nature of a service business nobody I
know that if you look at you have real
clients and look at the knowledge you're
getting like you have all these
Millennials out here and like they
different aren't they I don't think I
should I don't think in answers hi you
know what I think that's a popular
conversation I think people are pretty
basic
do they like yeah I think that they've
the same tried and true things which is
they have some balance of their wants
and needs I just think that they have
more power they do they've more power
because the world has gone in their
favor
they're 20-something in a time where
20-somethings are respected by 40 50 and
60 something's around business because
business is being done here and they
know when they're looking at
that they're like I could be him and I
can do what he does I hope not because
then they're [ __ ] stupid yeah I think
they're looking I think I'm looking
around the room I think a lot of more
like I could be trying you know what's
funny I hope they feel that way but they
it won't happen alright India let's go
what's up Gary and team had the use of
here off of your inspiration I started
vlogging my startup journey I've been
interacting with online communities like
the great vaynernation and just making
sure that I'm putting out good content
but aside from patience and thinking
about the long game
what are some things that someone like
me should be doing to grow his audience
thanks a lot
so I think one thing that stands up for
me and then you'll jump in Jason is I
think more real life stuff like every
meet up like like Jase you might
remember this when I first got I mean
it's really fun to get your perspective
nastain into the ecosystem I was pouring
wine at a jacuz Leo Laporte Meetup
yeah I'm a wine guy yeah I mean I was
were like I'm that guy I was service I
was to help basically I mean I don't
want to say but it's kind of true and so
and so like we need wine here and made a
new I'll I mean while I had the biggest
business in the room everybody else had
business on paper you actually had a
business but I was willing to earn my
keep into the ecosystem that's the
advice I would give here which is if
you're documenting your journey amazing
but go to every I mean Israel such a
hotbed for tech startups and just
startups in general go to every meet up
meet every person be part of the
ecosystem I think you did that extremely
well that's right when I started smoking
our reporter here I were so now a
reporter shirt every day I had 20 of
them so I was the brand and I would show
up every party and I have copies of the
magazine you have to be the brand you
have to be everywhere but a little hack
for him might be be the most intelligent
question under the most important
people's blog posts or their tweets in
other words really take your time forget
about building your own content your own
audience find somebody who's got an
audience that you would like to acquire
and be the most intelligent person in
there that's them for a while which is
kind of what you do like you meet the
guy to be like well this guy's
passionate wine but I'm here to see leo
but this guy's also kind of interesting
too right and so if you can put yourself
in Fred will
since comments on ABC it's like who it
is people you know it's a really high
lethality this is really smart
especially in the Facebook ecosystem
where if it's actually that it populates
up yeah
they trend it up the best comment goes
up but this takes time and you have to
not be thinking about yourself with your
comic that's the problem to build a
brand so they think it's their pitching
instead of bringing value to the
community of the micro community within
that blog post correct yep what is the
topic we're talking yeah and how do you
say something highly intelligent and who
you were further the conversation and to
you because you don't come from 20 years
of experience 30 years experience you
need to put your lens on it by the way
there's a lot for people reading
comments on those blogs that are just
like you entrepreneurs are trying to
make it then us reading it and so so you
saying here's my perspective from an
Israeli lead startup that from a 23 year
olds perspective you'll get a lot of
juice from that you need to own it
there's way too many people trying to
fake the funk right now that there are
so genius business people and they have
no experience under their fingernails
there's nothing more like I think
appealing than somebody who's a young
entrepreneur understand how this works
can somebody explain it to me or help me
because I really would like to be
successful people will come out and help
you hundred percent if you deploy the
humility and don't fake it yeah he's no
reason to fail I go on to well everybody
doesn't and by the way I've been there
like like when you don't when you're not
there yet you kind of wanna you want to
say yes and this and it was just not
smart I should have said please tell me
in this Melvin got there faster in my
meetings anytime a word comes up that I
don't know I said what does that mean
you know this is beauty but and I
wouldn't even have meanings then because
I'm terrible at like vocab you had like
and then somebody's like oh do you know
about this and I'm like what is that and
I just say explain to me what that is
and the like oh it's an acronym for this
and now okay now I'm getting smaller
yeah a hundred percent any let's move
this I know we got it I got a call last
one that's call David whoa David's in a
suit hey this is David Villa in Tampa
Florida I'm the CEO of
IPD and hey Gary I got a question for
you how do you deal with the sacred cow
or the top performer in your business
that generates a ton of business but
it's toxic to your company culture
fired
fired fired Amidala's fire david but let
me use the anything else top fired even
before you finish right good good guess
fired fired fired yeah fire it's fired
life is short
it's not even about like living your
best life and life is short it's you
lose like you lose like you just gonna
cap out it's like it's like math based
marketing eventually you run out of time
and like you can only extract so much
you know what it's like you know you
have someone like JR smith on your team
and like he's eventually going to
implode and cost you a championship
well i like don't go in that town no
junior smith junior smith as the number
one on that team
yeah when the top performer is toxic you
are finished it's game over yet the
other thing by the way is you have to be
the most you have to be the top
performer like like to me that is the
number one thing that i've always loved
about my businesses which is like i
don't know I just don't rely on anybody
at like I could never imagine running a
business that I would sit there and say
if d-roc way scared you scared of that
guy quitting because he's the top sales
100% that's why you see the fear inside
doesn t be like well I'll just do this
house you wouldn't even ask that
question yeah there's a boy in a car
salesman world there's a billion great
car assessment by the way in the comment
section if your tremendous car salesman
and up for moving leave economy are
Jason you get to ask the question of the
day any question you want great focus
group of hundreds if not thousands of
answers inside of Facebook and YouTube
what's on your mind to young
entrepreneurs and business people and
social media peeps what are you curious
about these days what are you looking at
is your prove been a very successful
investor you've been absolutely
historically correct on trends even the
people that love to razz you and things
that not deny the fact that you've seen
things play out properly with your
business of Virginia where thank
goodness yeah by the way as people that
have put themselves out there you get
your pros and your cons of that like
nothing Trump's the resume having wins
helps its air cover as I tell people you
know when they criticize whatever my I'm
just a guy
time's right just a just eight times but
you know like at a certain point if you
just keep hustling and you have one of
those Windsor by the way that number
really three or four and you've made
like like is it really like I'm
imagining yeah you know I'm Jo about
like so for example please an LP and a
fund yes that fund Sokka I can't say
which one it was not Sokka but it was in
that stock certificate up there got it
and it was in whatsapp yep and I just
got a call one day and they're like by
the way you have these two huge wins and
I say I didn't know I had those wins but
somebody may get investments um I gather
things happen I just sold my book and
I'm doing a book on angel investing and
Holly luck Hollis I know Harper I win it
just so you know little but not only
that but little behind the scenes I get
calls from Hollis once in a while like
what's the story here and usually I'm
like and this and I'm like on this one
no no she was like Carrie went to bat
for you oh very nice IRA and you guys
know I'd hate to go to bat for sure no
any I don't go to bat so okay so my
question for everybody is what do you
think the future is of employment now
that we have robotics and AI and what
are your solutions if in fact we see a
lot of jobs go away how would you solve
the problem of a society with let's say
20% less jobs available which would
increase unemployment which you know we
say the number three or four purse and
right now but it really does include
people who gave up which is another 15%
so what if we lived in a world where the
majority of people couldn't find a job
and only half the people employed how
would you try to solve for that in a
creative way because in our industry we
debate this but we all and in the past
we've always come up with new jobs but
it feels like this could be the
different time Joe bide I was at an
event where Joe Biden spoke I don't and
the reason I'm name dropping is cuz
maybe maybe because he's got a quote out
there that could somebody can make this
completely tight because I could be
wrong I don't remember if he said it's
the number one job in America or the
number one job now I'm calling for
people that do not have a college degree
but whatever the punchline is and again
somebody leave a comment for
clarification he said the number one job
in the marketplace for is transportation
drivers right and he goes with this
looming
is the number-one job people have it
I've actually drivers right cab that's
right you know yeah I mean listen and by
the way that's what happens in
industrial revolutions
yeah like shits about to hit the fan and
what is the solution versus I yeah
that's just an open quite a big question
it's a big question yeah that's my uncle
coming out he's gonna come back next
summer
alright yeah let me know why they not
you Pro tweet here there we'll have you
asked a question and we'll link it up
alright good I need a little some she's
got all these kids here working on this
stuff I'm a new boy you're fundamentally
blown away by the youth of this
organization I whatever I have never
seen an organization this young I'm
looking around the room that kids
definitely in high school this kid Tyler
how old Winnie Tyler bang e99 Teddy's in
high school a ho oh look at this kids 21
yep that kids 25 26 she told you that
eraser tell me this kid how are you I'm
good I'm 45 nice number
put it this way you and I think you're
as old as the two people here no I get
it
I know you keep asking questions we'll
keep answering them